there are three different types of
t-tests the one sample t-test the
independent samples t-test and the
paired samples t-test
when do we use a one sample t-test we
use the one sample t-test when we want
to compare the mean of a sample with a
known reference mean example a chocolate
bar manufacturer claims that it's
chocolate bars weigh an average of 50
grams
to check this we take a sample of 30
bars and weigh them the mean value of
this sample is 48 grams now we can use a
one sample t-test to check if the mean
of 48 grams is significantly different
from the claimed 50 grams when do we use
the independent samples t-test
we use the t-test for independent
samples when we want to compare the
means of two independent groups or
samples we want to know if there is a
significant difference between these
means example we would like to compare
the effectiveness of two painkillers we
randomly divide 60 people into two
groups the first group receives track a
and the second group receives track B
using an independent t-test we can now
test whether there is a significant
difference in pain relief between the
two drugs when we use the pair samples
t-test we use the paired samples t-test
to compare the means of two dependent
groups example we want to know how
effective a diet is to do this we weigh
30 people before the diet and then weigh
exactly the same people after the diet
now we can look at the difference in
weight between before and after for each
subject we can now use a paired sample
t-test to test whether there is a
significant difference
in a paired sample the measurements are
available in pairs the pairs result for
example from repeated measurements with
the same people
independent samples are made up of
people and measurements that are
independent of each other here's an
interesting note the paired samples
t-test is very similar to the one sample
t-test we can also think of the paired
samples t-test as having one sample that
was measured at two different times we
then calculate the difference between
the paired values giving us a value for
one sample the difference is once minus
five once plus two ones minus one and so
on and so forth now we want to test
whether the mean value of the difference
just calculated deviates from a
reference value in this case zero this
is exactly what the one sample tdus does
what are the assumptions for a t-test of
course we first need a suitable sample
in the one sample t-test we need a
sample and a reference value in the
independent t-test we need two
independent samples and in the case of a
pair t-test a pair sample the variable
for which we want to test whether there
is a difference between the means must
be metric examples of metric variables
are age body weight and income for
example a person's level of education is
not a metric variable in addition the
metric variable must be normally
distributed in all three t-test variants
in case of an independent t-test the
variances in the two groups must be
approximately equal you can check
whether the variances are equal using
Levine's test for more information watch
my video on Levine's test so while the
hypotheses of the t-test let's start
with the one sample t-test in the one
sample t-test the null hypothesis is the
sample mean is equal to the given
reference value so there's no difference
and the alternative hypothesis is the
sample mean is not equal to the given
reference value what about the
independent samples t-test in the
independent t-test the null hypothesis
is the mean values in both groups are
the same so there's no difference
between the two groups and the
alternative hypothesis is the mean
values in both groups are not equal so
there is a difference between the two
groups and finally the paired samples
t-test in a pair T Test the null
hypothesis is the mean of the difference
between the pairs is zero and the
alternative hypothesis is the mean of
the difference between the appears is
not zero but how do we calculate a
t-test to do this we first calculate the
T value to calculate the T value we need
two values first we need the difference
between the means and then we need the
standard deviation from the mean this is
also known as the standard error in a
one sample t-test we calculate the
difference between the sample mean and
the known reference mean as is the
standard deviation of the collected data
and N is the number of cases as divided
by the square root of n is then the
standard deviation from the mean which
is the standard error in a dependent
samples t-test we simply calculate the
difference between the two sample means
to calculate the standard error we need
the standard deviation and the number of
cases from the first and second sample
depending on whether we can assume equal
or unequal variance for our data there
are different formulas for the standard
error read more about this in our
tutorial on datadeep.net in a paired
sample t-test we only need to calculate
the difference between the paired values
and calculate the mean from that the
standard error is then the same as for a
one sample t-test so what have we
learned so far about the T value no
matter which t-test we calculate the T
value will be greater if we have a
greater difference between the means and
the T value will be smaller if the
difference between the means is smaller
for further the T value becomes smaller
when we have a larger dispersion of the
mean so the more scattered the data the
less meaningful a given mean difference
is
I hope you enjoyed the video and see you
next time